speaking of problems with the Trump
administration Pat there is there's this
there's trouble and I wouldn't call them
Camelot but Steve benen and jared
kushner are in a bit of a cat fight for
control over the White House there are
even movements on both sides of the of
the spectrum hashtag fire kushner
hashtag fire Bannon so the entire Trump
administration and following is divided
on this but it looks as though this is
not going to go well for Steve benen
Donald Trump in an interview said on
yesterday he said I like Steve but you
have to remember he was not involved in
my campaign until very late I had
already beaten the Senators and all the
governors and I didn't know Steve I'm my
own strategist and I wasn't like it
wasn't like I was going to change
strategies because I was facing crooked
Hillary so if if you had to take a bet
on who Donald Trump was getting ready to
decide with and this divide between
kushner and then and I think it's pretty
clear he's going to stick with his son
of man well even without that statement
he's obviously going to stick with his
own son-in-law and that's part of the
reason why nepotism shouldn't be allowed
in the White House right because jared
kushner is in la though he's able to get
around that but Ivanka Trump is Donald
Trump's favorite person in the whole
world and he's not going to Heidi's not
going to fire her husband right
especially because the I mean all in all
I mean Kushner might actually be the
most competent person in the White House
so it would be crazy for Donald Trump to
get rid of them and by competent I don't
mean qualified I mean he can read I mean
he could probably digest the the the
security briefings better than Donald
Trump can and Steve benen seems like
he's just an outsider trying to get in
but if Trump chooses to fire Ben and
there could be a lot of backlash
particularly on the Breitbart website
because Breitbart at this point given
the Trump attacks on Syria are already
willing to distance themselves yet way
from Trump oh and Bannon having worked
for a trump for months now would
possibly have some dirt on him yeah but
you know I think that's an inevitable
outflow of who Donald Trump really was
Donald Trump has no problem using and
utilizing anyone right and to to get
what he needs from them he needed
all training he needed the Breitbart
contingency and now he no longer needs
them at least he feels like he doesn't
need them he's going to put all of his
eggs in the basket of his son-in-law he
Donald Trump said one last thing in
regard to the misted that was happening
in the White House and this lets you
know clearly how he stands he says steve
is a good guy but in regards to the mess
happening in the White House he says
straighten it out or I will I mean that
type of language clearly suggests that
he has very little if any respect for
Steve benen and Steve benen is going to
lose in this catfight between kushner
abandon the irony of it is is that
Kushner has no qualifications right
Kushner is rich Kushner is a businessman
but he has no qualifications to be in
Iraq and speaking to foreign heads of
state Donald Trump is leveraging him in
this capacity so we're dealing with a
cabinet of and advisors full of
incompetent and so we're seeing a
catfight between two and competent
people not qualified to work in the
White House and Donald Trump is decide
and get by siding on the side of his son
alone